[Música]
hebras 24 es el momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología yo soy Andrés Meza
Muñoz y estoy aquí en reemplazo de mi
compañera Valentina Torres Sánchez es un
placer acompañarlos vamos a dedicar este
espacio a conocer un poco más de los
novelas científicos de este año y
empezamos con el galardón de Medicina
otorgado al biólogo sueco espante pavo
por según el comunicado del comité Nobel
del instituto carolinska sentar las
bases que permitieron desarrollar una
disciplina científica completamente
nueva la paleogenómica al revelar las
diferencias genéticas que distinguen a
todos los humanos vivos de los homínidos
extintos sus descubrimientos
proporcionaron la base para explorar lo
que nos hace únicamente humanos en otras
palabras el trabajo de pavo consistió en
identificar el genoma de los
neardentales y demostrar que los Homo
Sapiens tuvieron sexo e hijos con ellos
además únicamente a partir del ADN logró
identificar una nueva especie los
denisovanos
descubrió las secuencias genéticas de
nuestros parientes más cercanos los
homínidos neardentales y denisovanos
[Música]
diferencias entre estas formas humanas
extintas y nosotros como humanos hoy
permitirán descubrir importantes
informaciones sobre nuestras funciones
corporales y como nuestros cerebro se ha
ido desarrollando uno de los hallazgos
clave del trabajo de pago demuestra que
el cruce entre los neandertales y los
Homo Sapiens como una práctica
recurrente hace miles de años hizo que
todos los humanos que nacieron fuera de
África lleven un pequeño porcentaje de
ADN ardental en cada una de sus células
esos genes también han determinado Cómo
funciona el sistema inmune o cómo las
personas pueden vivir a grandes
altitudes
sabemos que algunas secuencias que se
derivan de los neardentales son
importantes factores de riesgo en las
infecciones Así que es relevante
identificarlo en pacientes
pavos considerado el padre de la
paleogenómica y sus compañeros lo
catalogan como un visionario de
temperamento fuerte actualmente es el
director del departamento de genética
del instituto Max planck de biología
evolutiva en Alemania
lo que conduce nuestro trabajo es la
curiosidad diría yo es como hacer una
excavación arqueológica para indagar
sobre el pasado hacemos algo como
excavaciones en el genoma humano y de
ello han salido implicaciones prácticas
por ejemplo descubrimos durante la
pandemia de Kobe 19 que el mayor factor
de riesgo para enfermarse seriamente y
morir cuando contraías el virus venía a
los humanos modernos de los neardentales
Hablamos ahora del Nobel de física el
comité Nobel de la Real Academia sueca
de ciencias entre huelgalardón al
francés Alan Spec al estadounidenses
John Francis closer y alastria austriaco
Antón silenger considerados Pioneros de
la comunicación cuántica el comunicado
Explica lo que le ocurre a una partícula
en un par entrelazado determina lo que
le ocurre a la otra Incluso si están tan
lejos para afectarse mutuamente el
desarrollo de herramientas
experimentales por parte de los
laureados ha sentado las bases de una
nueva era en la tecnología cuántica
Este es un trabajo que además de 50 años
empecé cuando era un estudiante graduado
escribió un ensayo en 1969 proponiendo
hacer un experimento original para
probar las bases de la mecánica cuántica
los resultados son muy importantes para
la cuántica y la encriptación en
particular para el envío de
comunicaciones seguras
el trabajo se apoya en las teorías de
John Stuart Bell que en 1964 aseguró que
si dos partículas tenían una interacción
a distancia no era por variables ocultas
en otras palabras instrucciones que les
indicaban a esas partículas que
resultado deben dar en un experimento
años después closer confirmó la teoría
en un laboratorio y luego aspect y
sailinger por separado fueron incluso
más precisos en sus experimentos
Fantastic creo que muestra que la
cuántica que es fantástica ha estado en
la agenda por más de un siglo y aún hay
muchos misterios cosas más misteriosas
por descubrir muestra que la cuántica
sigue viva
un desarrollo muy prometedor son los
simuladores cuánticos es decir las
computadoras cuánticas que se construyen
para procesos específicos para la
simulación de cuerpos sólidos etcétera y
últimamente ha habido resultados muy
interesantes pero todavía no están
listos para el consumidor promedio
siempre digo que sabremos que todo esto
se está aplicando una vez que no
tengamos que sostener esto en nuestras
manos por último pero no menos
importante está el Nobel de química que
también fue entregado por la academia
sueca que este año fue para Barry
sharkles mortemmedal y Caroline
bertosimedal son considerados Pioneros
de la llamada química del click y
bertosi logró aplicarla en el interior
de células vivas
este premio se concede a una nueva forma
de fabricar moléculas grandes y
complejas y otros materiales es ver la
química como un Lego tienes algo así
como piezas que unes de una manera muy
sencilla Esto es lo que es la química de
click Y a lo que se refiere de click que
simplemente como un clic las cosas se
unen y se construye algo mayor el camino
lo empezó sharkles cuando cerca del año
2000 sentó las bases de la química del
click una modalidad simple y confiable
en donde las reacciones ocurren rápido y
se evitan los subproductos no deseados
luego tanto sharkpolls como metal
trabajando por separado crearon el
procedimiento conocido como ciclo
adicional quinoacida catalizada por
cobre una reacción que en términos
actualmente se usa para producir
fármacos para mapeo del ADN crear nuevos
materiales y por último bertosi
consiguió mapear glicanos unos azúcares
que están en la superficie de las
células y que son marcadores biológicos
del cáncer así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía y los invitamos a que continúen
con nosotros en 24 y France 24.com
[Música]